oh oh hi reject may hi everybody I'm
John Humphrey I have them excellent the
MEC since double toasted Dom we played I
dropped it it's okay
John Humphrey real rejects sammy
gonzales double toasted them excellent
as well we are here party people we out
here as they say and we're gonna watch
some tommy wiseau today for shizzle you
you like dark night yes I do you like
Tommy always Oh I love Tommy Wiseau
which one do you like better Tommy oh my
stomach's have never hurt so much
watching The Dark Knight you're still
after seven stomach like oh I mean like
what is going on I'm a big boy I'm the
only way you get that is seven stomachs
that's impressive that I mean like see
I'm to have like a men and black thing
where I'm just like I just want to take
you apart and study this [ __ ] that's for
men in black or something I don't see
movies oh [ __ ] that's like my premise
but I have seen the room and I have
heard the audiobook of the disaster
artist so I'm like Tommy we so ready
you're destroying your legacy right now
well let's hop into this then if you're
telling me wise I mean I came prepared I
got this Dark Knight t-shirt and my
tummy was so jacket you see that there's
official this is full fandom right here
before we hop into this just want to
shine a little light on our patreon feed
we do some pretty cool stuff over there
got a some stuff thanks man thank you
for being a patron always checking out
all the content you should we got
full-length TV show reactions for
riverdale attack on Titan Gotham Gotham
yeah Gotham Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood supernatural oh my hero
academia anime yep and also q and A's
great people a whole bunch more so come
check us out over there would love if
you become a patron objectin thanks so
apparently this is through Nerdist and
it's just a recreation of the
interrogation scene from The Dark Knight
should be fun
funny story Batman ha ha hold this
football that's comfortable oh yeah yeah
whatever makes you feel happy
you know whatever whatever's getting on
yeah there we go that's kind of that
makes me happy
[Music]
in March nor this Bry you Tommy with
cells Joker audition tape now we bring
you we need more cowbell I want to see
what you disappoint you let five people
die and you let Dan take your place give
it to a guy like me that's called
worsted toes mobster those fools wants
you gone so they can go back they cannot
go by who are you why did you change
everything forever ha ha ha then why do
you want to kill me I don't want it kill
you why should I kill you what I would
do without you
you you complete your garbage
then you are not you are not just a
freak like me they need you right now
but when they don't pass you out I shown
you what the chips go down and civilized
people they will eat you over just like
that which is the only way to live in
this world
this will our rules and tonight
you're going to beg you know for a while
you throw yourself the other your friend
is history
or is blushing bride you have nothing
now that is read me we're never to do a
lot your spray
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
watch have fun thank you very much
[Music]
right one cuz Greg Sestero is a bad
actor you want to talk about Tommy Tommy
Lee's commits well cuz Tommy has his own
gravitational field right like the thing
about him especially like as highlighted
by this is he will dip in and out of
compelling yeah cuz there are moments
where Tommy is legit in this right like
I said there are moments really right
yeah but like to think so though he's
getting thrown on the table and he's
laughing like that seems real he's in a
strange way where I was like there's
something there like it really is
something there but then his broken
English comes out it's like yeah over
the word he's Kaden cuz mouth is all too
open sometimes and it's like Sal he's
remembering stuff right yeah you're
garbage
greg was bad the whole time this is
weird because I feel like whatever role
you plug the two of them into is always
gonna change the dynamic of who's doing
a better job because in this one I feel
like the odds are just stacked
incredibly in Tommy's favour of course
cuz like the first thing I started think
about is it must just be awkward for any
actor to have to let crunchy do the
right and then growl through that as
yeah Greg
is not who I think wristband yeah
sakura-san bail you know or or heck even
like no on ham maybe Affleck salad that
could be cool I mean I've always wanted
him to play Superman honestly John have
yeah which is weird cuz I prefer Batman
as character but here's thing I've
always wanted Tommy Wiseau to play
Superman so that's kind of where I'm at
that's kind of where I'm at with this
whole thing truth justice the American
Way
he's more American than Israel American
games you look horrible
he does she loves football because it's
American so no one else's American old
school Superman that that is a hundred
percent shoot with justice in the
America why oh man it's funny we just
actually saw this again in IMAX which
was incredible and yet like seeing this
scene especially like really sang and so
now to see it again like twisted in on
itself is really fascinating and it kind
of reminds you that Christopher Nolan's
Batman the cowl like you're mentioned
like the face squish doesn't look good
the face part doesn't hold up to me I
feel like I love efflux costume both
iterations okay a little more the gray
the gray body and it's little warm
little a latex II but like this is very
like restrictive I know it's realistic
but lift facial lines and the cheekbones
always kind of weird for me and so
watching someone else who doesn't have
like a defined jaw line without the the
aura of what Batman is yeah like
Batman's silly boy I mean on the flip
side the Joker would be silly if you
have someone that just has no charisma
or any sort of aura about them say what
you will about Jared Leto he had
something it was wrong but he had
something yeah one also I mean and I
don't want to go to bat for him but also
just the movie didn't really help him
right right I didn't even know Greg
Sestero was in this know that was that I
knew that that was like the dynamic was
like those two guys pitching their movie
but yeah Tommy was so just thinking
about like the Joker in real life like
that kind of flashed in my head like it
wouldn't be some Heath Ledger like
handsome dudes just like so wicked and
whimsical it'd be some like random older
crazy dude
weird background nobody knows like Tommy
Wiseau's real background some people
have sleuth around and figure some stuff
out he's like I've been in like three
car accidents and I've almost died a
couple times like that's what the Joker
would be yeah do it like CTE I have two
people I'm gonna blow them up hahaha
that's why that kind of works it's like
he looks intimidating and scary because
he's a weird-looking dude yeah Joker
strung-out demeanor
yeah the Joker in like The Dark Knight
realistically is a handsome guy a
charismatic guy yeah there's be girls
that if that were in real life you know
the the groupies for like serial killers
you know those girls right like in real
life I come from the horrid community
you mean a lot of those real white if
that were the case like they'd be like
Oh Heath Ledger Joker so handsome they
wouldn't do that for this guy though
because this guy's [ __ ] nuts
and that's what the Joker is he's nuts
but brilliant at the same time I met a
few people for whom just psychosis is a
turn-on so I don't even know if he's
just like just flat rate attractiveness
would even factor I was wonder I wonder
his is attract and this is just it's off
the charts for me right here look at
that yeah man but you know who else is
super attractive
me you but you know who else is is
attract [ __ ] more attractive than you
because this is the real rejects channel
on the house always wins
Daniel gala sure Daniel Gallacher paints
from the day shoutout how's it going
buddy Daniel Gallacher good together
just or jealous share going gala share
is it's like share the famed singer
share you need to parlay that into some
kind of World Tour annual gala gala
share is gone handsome gala free one
news is a handsome dude lives in
Scotland trained to be a farm assistant
is my theory that that is how you are
going to become the real-life Joker you
know cuz Pharmaceuticals man not only
are you around chemicals that are
supposed to alter your mind and body but
also I mean chemistry things let's go
wrong and and pharmacies are in the back
of a lot of grocery stores and there's a
whole chemical aisle that you could just
have splash on top of you dude yeah
leach gone fell down you know a couple
the shelves ACK on top of you who pretty
soon your complexions all messed up you
got a smile ingrained and that'd be
hilarious that you almost died by having
cleaning products fall on you and
bleaching your skin white yeah you would
be like a scary Joe curry Michael
Jackson exactly and then you go to the
pharmacy be hopped up on drugs and then
you sound like Tommy Wiseau and then the
whole thing is complete find a friend
and I want you to recreate this scene
from The Dark Knight I want to hear what
you sound like in the may you're gonna
be Tommy was out for this video you're
gonna get in the makeup and you're gonna
do it you're gonna need a separate
Harvey and Rachel make Batman go after
minutes and make sure your accent is as
obvious as possible don't hide it yeah
Scottish accent I want it anyhow you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell to get updated
every time a review or a video is out
cuz why would the subscribe button do
what it's supposed to do sammy gonzales
the mix aligns the underscore Mixel ins
on the Twitter's and Instagram all
double toasted double toasted fanpage
doses calm not calm scribe Sammy ain't
seen [ __ ] Thursdays
no [ __ ] Friday this time but Thursdays
you lyin to my audience Ernest so much
so much I don't see movies done so if
you want to see movies it's good